Superkomputer klasik terbaik kita terus makin canggih,
dan kita makin jago dalam komputasi, termasuk simulasi sistem.
Tapi mensimulasikan alam itu pada dasarnya masalah yang sangat susah.
Nama saya Victoria Lipinska dan hari ini kita akan menjelajahi salah satu algoritma
yang bisa membuat simulasi alam jadi mungkin di komputer kuantum.
Kita mulai dengan contoh, yaitu kafein.
Ini molekul yang sederhana.
Untuk merepresentasikan konfigurasi energi dari satu molekul kafein saja,
kita butuh sekitar sepuluh pangkat 48 bit.
Itu angka sepuluh dengan 48 nol
dan itu sekitar 10% dari jumlah atom di bumi.
Dan ternyata masih bisa lebih parah.
Kalau kamu punya 125 orbital dan mau menyimpan semua kemungkinan
konfigurasi, kamu butuh memori
di komputer klasik melebihi jumlah atom di alam semesta.
Itu mustahil direpresentasikan oleh superkomputer.
Tapi ada harapan untuk komputer kuantum,
karena secara intrinsik mereka memang unggul dalam simulasi alam.
Untuk molekul kafein, itu berarti merepresentasikan
sistemnya menggunakan 160 qubit.
Kedengarannya jauh lebih masuk akal.
Berbagai algoritma kuantum sudah diusulkan yang memungkinkan
komputer kuantum yang lebih kecil mensimulasikan alam secara heuristik.
Hadirkan: variational quantum eigensolver atau VQE.
VQE adalah algoritma yang berjalan sebagian di komputer kuantum
dan sebagian lagi di komputer klasik.
Algoritma ini memungkinkan kita menemukan nilai yang menyelesaikan masalah optimasi tertentu.
VQE sangat berkaitan erat dengan metode lain yang melibatkan
variasi parameter seperti quantum approximate optimization algorithm.
Mengidentifikasi aplikasi VQE di industri atau penelitian kamu
itu semacam seni tersendiri, tapi ada panduan umumnya.
Secara umum, VQE bisa diterapkan pada masalah yang bisa dirumuskan
sebagai masalah optimasi dengan variabel kontinu.
Ini terjadi, misalnya, di banyak bidang kimia kuantum.
Seringkali dalam kimia, kita tertarik pada ground state.
Ground state adalah keadaan sistem dengan energi paling rendah.
Untuk menemukan energi ground state, VQE menjelajahi
energi untuk berbagai konfigurasi sistem
dan mencari konfigurasi dengan energi terendah.
Secara garis besar, VQE menerima deskripsi sistem kuantum
dan mencari energi terendah.
Ini dilakukan dengan memvariasikan konfigurasi sistem.
Untuk memulai, kita harus memasukkan deskripsi sistem yang sesuai
yang bisa dipahami komputer kuantum beserta sekumpulan parameter yang mendeskripsikannya
yang akan dioptimalkan.
Bagian kuantum dari
algoritma ini menyiapkan sistem dalam suatu keadaan
yang dideskripsikan oleh sekumpulan parameter tertentu dan menghitung energinya.
Sementara bagian klasiknya bertanggung jawab
untuk mengoptimalkan parameter-parameter itu di setiap langkah.
Proses kuantum-klasik ini diulang
sampai kita mencapai energi terendah.
Sekarang mari kita lihat lebih dekat apa yang terjadi di balik layar.
Konfigurasi energi biasanya dideskripsikan dalam Hamiltonian
dan biasanya itu adalah matriks yang sangat besar.
Dalam aljabar, untuk mencari eigenvalue terkecil dari matriks
yang bersesuaian dengan energi terendah sistem,
kita cukup melakukan singular value decomposition.
Namun, matriks yang akan kita hadapi berukuran eksponensial
dan ini adalah masalah yang eksponensial sulitnya jika dikerjakan secara aljabar.
Hamiltonian ini harus direpresentasikan dalam bentuk
yang bisa dipahami komputer kuantum.
Jadi diterjemahkan dari bahasa kimia ke bahasa komputasi kuantum.
Jangan khawatir soal detailnya.
Pada akhirnya ada cara-cara terprogram untuk menerjemahkan Hamiltonian yang biasanya
dipakai dalam kimia ke dalam Hamiltonian yang bisa dipahami komputer kuantum.
Lalu kita masukkan
Hamiltonian ini bersama circuit, yang kita sebut variational form.
Memilih variational form itu semacam seni tersendiri.
Sekali lagi,
itu mewakili tebakan terbaik kita tentang seperti apa keadaan kuantum sistem tersebut.
Variational circuit ini diparameterisasi dengan sekumpulan parameter theta,
dan kita juga memasukkan pilihan awal dari parameter-parameter ini.
Berdasarkan ini, bagian kuantum dari VQE:
menyiapkan reference state, misalnya keadaan nol;
menggunakan parameterized quantum circuit, yaitu variational form, untuk menyiapkan keadaan kuantum
untuk tebakan awal parameter di komputer kuantum; dan mengestimasi
energi yang bersesuaian dengan keadaan yang dievaluasi melalui Hamiltonian.
Estimasi energi ini kemudian dikirim
ke classical optimizer, yang mencari sekumpulan parameter baru.
Parameter-parameter itu dikirim kembali ke quantum solver,
dan seluruh prosesnya diulang.
Komputer kuantum menemukan estimasi energi baru,
classical optimizer menemukan sekumpulan parameter baru, dan seterusnya.
Kita ulangi proses ini sampai solusinya konvergen.
Artinya sampai perbedaan hasil antar langkah sudah cukup kecil
sesuai kebutuhan kita.
Di akhirnya, algoritma mengembalikan energi yang sudah diminimalkan itu.
Oke, ini bagus sekali.
Tapi mungkin kamu bertanya-tanya bagaimana kita tahu ini benar-benar berhasil
dan kita nggak akan secara tidak sengaja menemukan energi yang lebih rendah dari yang kita cari?
Pertanyaan yang bagus.
Ternyata kita nggak bisa pernah mengestimasi energi yang lebih rendah.
Ini berkat sesuatu yang kita sebut variational principle.
Variational principle menyatakan bahwa batas bawah terbesar
dari energi sistem selalu merupakan
energi terendahnya yang bersesuaian dengan ground state.
Ini berarti energi yang dievaluasi pada keadaan lain manapun dari sistem tersebut
akan selalu lebih besar dari energi terendah.
Oleh karena itu, dengan VQE kita nggak bisa pernah mendapatkan sesuatu
yang lebih rendah dari energi ground state.
Tapi kita memang bisa konvergen ke sesuatu
yang lebih besar dari minimum yang kita cari.
Ini sering disebut solusi metastabil
dan itu adalah tantangan yang para peneliti coba selesaikan setiap harinya.
VQE berguna karena menggunakan circuit yang lebih dangkal
dibanding protokol lain yang memungkinkan kita mengestimasi energi ground state.
Ini membuatnya cocok untuk hardware kuantum jangka dekat.
Di video ini, kita sudah sekilas melihat apa yang bisa dilakukan VQE dan bagaimana ia dibangun.
Tapi saya mendorong kamu untuk mengeksplorasi Qiskit dalam konteks ini.
Meski kita masih di awal perjalanan kuantum kita,
kamu mungkin sudah bisa menemukan kegunaannya untuk masalah yang sedang kamu coba selesaikan.
Nama saya Victoria Lipinska dan ini adalah gambaran umum
dari algoritma variational quantum eigensolver.